THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
AS SOON AS ROBERT MUELLER WAS
APPOINTED SPECIAL COUNSEL IN THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION,
POLITICIANS RUSHED TO COVER HIM
WITH A BLANKET OF INVINCIBILITY.
>> HAVE YOU SEEN ANYTHING IN
THIS INVESTIGATION THAT WOULD
SUGGEST HE HAS A CONFLICT?
>> I HAVEN'T.
I SIT ON THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ALONG WITH SENATOR  , AND I HAVE
NOT SEEN ANY EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST
THAT.
>> I DO NOT AT ALL BELIEVE THAT
MR. MUELLER HAS BEEN COMPROMISED
>> I HAVE A LOT OF ADMIRATION
AND RESPECT FOR DIRECTOR
MUELLER.
>> YOU'VE GOT SOMEBODY WHO, BY
ALL ACCOUNTS, IS AN INDEPENDENT
PERSON.
>> HE ENJOYS VERY BROAD SUPPORT
BECAUSE OF HIS LONG SERVICE AS
AS A SENIOR FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
>> Laura: IN OTHER WORDS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP, DON'T YOU DARE
RUSHED INTO PROPOSE LEGISLATION
INTERFERENCE OR TERMINATION.
REPUBLICAN PRO-AMNESTY CENTER
TOM TILLIS, ALONG WITH LIBERAL
DELAWARE SENATOR CHRIS COONS
INTRODUCED A BILL THAT WOULD
ALLOW MUELLER TO CHALLENGE ANY
REMOVAL IN COURT.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM AND
CORY BOOKER, WONDER TWIN POWERS
ACTIVATE, THEY WENT EVEN
FURTHER.
THEY SPONSORED A BILL THAT WOULD
PREVENT THE FIRING OF MUELLER.
APPARENTLY HE SO PERFECT HE
COULD NEVER BE FIRED.
SENATORS TED CRUZ AND MIKE LEE
WERE PROPERLY SKEPTICAL ABOUT
THE CONSTITUTIONALITY OF ANY
SUCH MOVES SUCH AS THAT.
REMEMBER, MUELLER WORKED FOR THE
OF COURSE THIS WOULD BE ABSURD.
AND IT WOULDN'T BE SMART, HE IS
THE HEAD OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
AND CONGRESS HAS NO BUSINESS
OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
ALL THEY HAVE IS THE
SO MY QUESTION IS WHY WERE THESE
WERE SO EAGER TO INSULATE THEM
FROM EXECUTIVE BRANCH OVERSIGHT
AND ULTIMATELY PERHAPS
TERMINATION?
THANK GOD WE HAVE DILIGENT
CONGRESSMAN WHO DO TAKE THEIR
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY
SERIOUSLY.
I'M TALKING ABOUT CONGRESSMAN
DEVIN NUNES, MATT GAETZ, TREY
GOWDY, ROBERT GOODLATTE AND
PETER KING, WHO WILL JOIN US IN
JUST A FEW MOMENTS.
YOU DON'T WANT TO MISS THIS
SEGMENT.
THEIR DETERMINATION TO SEE THAT
THIS INVESTIGATION DOESN'T TURN
INTO SOME KIND OF STAR CHAMBER.
IT'S ALREADY TURNED UP
INCREDIBLE THING SO FAR.
MISSING OR DISCUSSED THUMB
DRIVES.
TALK OF DELETING TEXT MESSAGES.
TALK OF CREATING INSURANCE
POLICIES AGAINST TRUMP.
MAYBE EVEN SECRET SOCIETIES IN
THE FBI.
MEETINGS CONVENED OUTSIDE OF THE
FBI.
AND OF COURSE ALL THOSE MISSING
TEXTS THAT THEY MAY OR MAY NOT
BE RECONSTRUCTING.
AND BY THE WAY, SPEAKING OF
THESE TEXTS BETWEEN PETER STRZOK
AND HIS GAL PAL LISA PAGE, WE
HEARD THIS TODAY FROM THE DOJ
TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN LISA PAGE
AND PETER STRZOK DURING THE TIME
PERIOD THAT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL IS INVESTIGATING.
WHAT WE ALSO KNOW, FOR ABOUT A
FIVE MONTH PERIOD THOSE TEXT
MESSAGES NEVER GOT INTO THE FBI
SERVER.
OBVIOUSLY WE ARE REVIEWING
IMMEDIATELY HOW THEY DIDN'T GET
INTO THE SERVER IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
>> Laura: FIRST OF ALL, WHO
HAS ANYTHING, THAT MUCH TO SAY
TO ANYONE THAT WOULD ACCOUNT FOR
50,000 TEXT?
THAT THE GLITCH THAT SHE
REFERENCED MAY HAVE AFFECTED
35,000 FBI EMPLOYEES AND ALL
THEIR CELL PHONES.
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT WE HEARD A
FEW DAYS AGO.
BUT WHATEVER THE CASE, IT
PROMPTS MORE QUESTIONS NOW JUST
ABOUT THE BASIC COMPETENCY OF
THE FBI.
SORRY, ARE WE NOT EVEN ALLOWED
TO WONDER WHAT ELSE PETER STRZOK
AND LISA PAGE SAID TO EACH OTHER
ABOUT TRUMP, FLYNN, COMEY, AND
MAYBE EVEN THE OLD HILLARY EMAIL
INVESTIGATION?
I'M SURE IT WASN'T ALL 50,000
MAYBE YOU HAVE AS WELL.
THE MORE WE LEARN, AND THE
CLOSER CONGRESS GETS TO THE
MEDIA ATTACKS ON THOSE PEOPLE
SOCIETIES.
>> THIS IS NONSENSE, IT'S JUST
COMPLETE NONSENSE.
>> YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT THAT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A POLITICAL
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN HERE.
>> REPUBLICANS ARE TALKING ABOUT
THIS INSTITUTION, PART AND HAVE
THE KIND OF MORALE PROBLEMS THAT
COULD BE LONG-LASTING DOWN THE
ROAD.
TRASHING THE CURRENT PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
WELL, I'M JUST GLAD THE
THE FBI, YOU CAN NEVER QUESTION
THEM.
LET'S LOOK BACK NOW.
FOR YEARS THE LEFT HAS INDULGED
GROUPS LIKE BLACK LIVES MATTER,
AND CHARACTER OF POLICE.
ANYTIME SOMEBODY CATCHES ONE OF
THOSE UNPLEASANT CELL PHONE
VIDEOS THE POLICE ARE TOO
AGGRESSIVE, THEY ARE RACIST,
THEIR ANTI-MUSLIM.
VERSUS FEDERAL, BUT MUELLER IS
TARGETING TRUMP.
LAW ENFORCEMENT, YOU CAN'T
QUESTION THEM.
THEY CAN'T DO ANY WRONG.
IF THEY SHOULD NEVER BE FIRED,
THEY SHOULDN'T EVEN BE QUESTIONS
THEY SHOULDN'T EVEN BE QUESTION
SOME IN THE MEDIA WOULD HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF CURIOSITY ABOUT, I
COUNSEL'S OFFICE.
IF THEY DISTRUST LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND INVESTIGATORS ON THE STATE
LEVEL SO OFTEN, WHY DO THE FEDS
GET A PASS?
WELL, THERE IS WITHOUT A DOUBT A
DEEP-SEATED ANIMUS, AND THAT IS
PUTTING IT MILDLY, TOWARD THE
PRESIDENT BY KEY MEMBERS OF THE
GROWING EVIDENCE, THE LEFT, THEY
START DEMONIZING MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
AND ANYONE, FRANKLY ANYONE, WHO
DARES TO QUESTION THE METHODS
AND THE MOTIVES OF THE OBAMA
THE BLACK CLOUD THAT HANGS OVER
CREATED BY FOX NEWS.
IT CERTAINLY WASN'T CREATED BY
TALK RADIO.
NONE OF US HIRED JEANNIE REED,
WHO PREVIOUSLY WORKED FOR THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION AND
REPRESENTED OBAMA'S NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR, BEN RHODES.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS, FOX NEWS
AND TALK RADIO DID NOT APPOINT
ANDREW WEISSMANN.
SHE WAS FIRED BY THE PRESIDENT.
I DON'T THINK FOX NEWS AND TALK
RADIO APPOINTED PETER STRZOK
OF SCAPEGOATING IS GOING TO MAKE
THIS ANY BETTER.
ROBERT MUELLER COULD BE THE
GREATEST GUY, THE SMARTEST GUY
EVER, BUT IF THE MAN CANNOT
OVERSEE HIS OWN TEAM AND REMOVE
THE PARTISANS, THEN YOU HAVE TO
CONCLUDE HE IS EITHER IN OVER
HIS HEAD OR HE'S JUST NOT GOOD
FOR THIS ROLE, OR HIS NEGLIGENT
IN HIS DUTY.
AND THAT WILL COMPROMISE THE
ULTIMATE FINDINGS OF THIS
INVESTIGATION, WHATEVER THEY MAY
BE.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THIS.
TRUMP'S TEAM MADE SOME MISTAKES
EARLY ON.
I DO NOT THINK, AND I'VE SAID
THIS BEFORE, IT WAS SMART TO
TO LESTER HOLT ABOUT THE
DECISION TO FIRE JIM COMEY.
AND IF THE STORY IS TRUE, IT
VOTED IN THE ELECTION, I
WOULDN'T HAVE DONE THAT EITHER.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TO BE EXTRA
COMMUNITY WITH HIS PROMISE OF
REFORMS, AND OF COURSE SOME OF
HIS CRITICISMS.
YOU KICK THAT DEEP STATE HORNETS
NEST AND YOU ARE LIABLE TO GET
STUNG REALLY BAD.
TODAY, THE PRESIDENT TOLD
REPORTERS, HEY, I'M HAPPY TO
TALK TO MUELLER.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO TALK TO
MUELLER?
>> I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO IT
ACTUALLY.
>> YOU WANT TO?
>> THERE'S BEEN NO COLLUSION
WHATSOEVER.
THERE IS NO OBSTRUCTION
WHATSOEVER, AND I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO IT.
I WOULD LOVE TO DO THAT AND I
WOULD LIKE TO DO IT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
I WOULD DO IT.
>> Laura: I WAS LISTENING TO
THAT AUDIO.
HE SURE SEEMS LIKE HE HAS
NOTHING TO HIDE, AND THE
PRESIDENT APPEARS READY AND
WILLING TO BE HELD UP TO
SCRUTINY BY THE MUELLER TEAM.
HE WANTS TO CLEAR HIS NAME.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO ARE DOING THE SCRUTINIZING?
WHO IS GOING TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE?
NO ONE SHOULD BE ABOVE THE LAW.
NOT THE PRESIDENT, NOT